[Musik]
marco carini ist männerarzt er
beschäftigt sich mit dem man sein in all
seinen facetten und mit der frage wann
ist man einfach sagen als man weiß was
er will
zum wohle aller also nicht auf der
schuld drives kollegen der familie
chance im partners ihre partnerin aber
weiß gestellt und leistet sich
vorstellen was ist der mensch sie dass
sie das ist für mich stimmen aber nicht
mit mit seitigen ellenbogen und und
bandenchecks musiklabels haben
[Musik]
die malanik gebiete und die oberarme
möglich freimachen
es waren die folgen der finanzkrise die
marco carini dazu bewogen haben seine
männer praxis zu gründen
reihenweise brauchen manager in seinem
sprechzimmer damals in tränen aus er
beschloss sich fortan nicht mehr nur um
die männer körper zu kümmern denen zu
wenig sorge getragen wird sondern auch
um das männliche innenleben um den
ganzen mann halt 139 auf 82 rubrik in
ihrem jahrgang der die aber selten über
unzählige und rundlich mit 85 dass ich
doch so ganz zufrieden stellen
die sich mit bester freund generation
vor ihr leben so in den jüngsten
gebauten körper bewusst sie und und legt
sich mehr die alte wissmann nominierte
teamkapitän euro erzielt
das eigene verfahren oder was auch immer
das gefühl so oft indianer kein cash
marge und unternehmen stärken und so auf
die jüngere generation wird so körper
sensible haut wird dann sind die männer
holen auf auch in einem weiteren
geschäftszweig der männer praxis
das ist unser hobby vom inneren reibung
mehr manuell bis machen was ich sonst
sehe ich die medizin ist top box botox
sehr saal der botox eigentlich nur wie
man aber auch ganz bösen tritt ihre
songs folter
endlich also nicht im sinn von 80
gesteuert aber sie kann also zu schimmel
generell sich lieber aufs äußere und das
finde ich eigentlich nur neu bisher ins
das meer
mit musste aber selbstbewusst sie hätte
unter www ssigkeit im hofstaat den
sollen wir das machen für sie mit
hofstaat zu mir ins büro normal
sie wusste was man gemacht hat
auch außerhalb seiner praxis dreht sich
bei marco carini alles ums man sein
in workshops schon vor sieben jahren
hier im kloster engelberg bach weniger
von ihnen nimmt auch punktuell
regelmäßig jetzt noch nie sagt bisky der
summe jetzt
[Musik]
ehrlichkeit die teilnehmer am workshop
gipfeltreffen im kloster engelberg
nennen sich bringt auf zeit
sie alle wollen sich ein wochenende lang
unter ihresgleichen austauschen und so
der titel des seminars man sein
frei von den ansprüchen ihrer frauen
familien und vorgesetzten also gesetzt
kreismeister fest steht sie plötzlich zu
erlassen oder sind sowohl völlig neu
sind für immer verlassen ja ok mit rinde
spielen
[Musik]
für unsere generation deutscher bratman
definiert oder private sind emanzipiert
und erhält damit um
und ich hoffe ich suche nach dem wasser
nicht ohne sie vor dem gipfel grafisch
ganz nah sein was heißt dass sie also
prima mal wirklich aber größere
einsparungen in die man direkt die kinos
bringen wo mir sehr langsam druck macht
und noch einmal der klassische
rollenbild von der ec-karte männliche
geschlecht und wo jetzt ja dank der
letzten 40 jahre man situation oder eine
zusätzliche komponente gelegt hat und
dass ich die weibliche seite sind die
plenarvorträge aber auch nichts haltiger
und eigeninteresse
er sollte sagen ihr frage sind auch
ziemlich schnell kräfte überholspuren
bei uns mut gemacht und ist wieder vorne
beugen gar nicht so richtig passiert und
jetzt darf ich euch bitte minute tage
zimmer und 16 black minute laufen
geschlossenen augen was ist für den 6
das schwierigste ist allererste schritt
tage warm unsere sexualität definieren
wenn beide mit mehr wissen
denk und bisschen diskussion und da kann
man wirklich ganz vorsichtig fahren und
sagen wir machen jetzt sexualität als
spielfeld und alles was nicht in frage
kommt mini persönlicher note aus schrieb
ich hab s spielfeld und das kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen dass ich die im himmel
aber nicht gebraucht werden
denn hätte rund drei wochen klar das
nimmt ja eben auch sehr produktiver als
lustig erotisch monaten endet ribery
wichtig die sexuelle fantasien und das
spielfeld der kamera zone machen und
hart spielen das möchte ich wirklich
nicht verzichten und in der nabe zone
das ist verhandelbar auch sexualität die
muss man einfach handle weil es meiner
verhandelt es neben mir alles muss raus
darum haben wir ihn darin industrie so
unglaubliche um 6 ich würde auf die duh
fordert ist am ludwigsplatz
rasenspielfeld eine zweite frage der
beziehung 3 etc
geiles langes küssen und dabei geblasen
werden
juli 6 mit mehreren räumen gleichzeitig
und ausdauer richtig vom leder ziehen am
küchentisch bei offenem fenster
marco carini hat eine fachausbildung in
psychiatrie und bietet
gesprächstherapien an
und in dieser funktion kümmert er sich
nicht nur männer sondern auch um deren
frauen
er begleitet scheidungsprozess coach bei
der suche nach lösungen wenn tritt
partner im spiel sind oder unterstützt
ganz einfach die beziehungspflege in
langzeitbeziehungen gut wehren uns ja
plus/minus 1 halbjahr nichts wo man ja
spitze beschlossen quasi als soft skills
über die paar zielpunkt und definiert
und dann eine sylvian christian
eichenberger sind seit 25 jahren
verheiratet in regelmäßigen abständen
buchen sie coaching termine bei marco
carini wo man ihre beziehung zu arbeiten
dabei geht es um die diskussion von
gemeinsamen und individuellen zielen und
werden um work life balance und
gemeinsamkeiten und eigenheiten um nähe
und distanz mit der finanzplan nicht nur
gegen das schön geordnet ans mit hand
andere ist auch honorierten die aufbaut
und bezieht wichtig und wenn wir den
moment nicht verpassen oder vielleicht
doch plötzlich abdriftet bislang weniger
schwer sein fachlichen ich will mir die
musik so hätte es gemacht und jetzt
plötzlich eine schlange und da haben wir
viele vermieter wenn man körperlich und
dem respekt ingo zu ermöglich um
intimität um sexualität und die haben
wir das letzte mal seit also
diesbezüglich gut ins gewollt sind
ich biss aber es stimmt dass mir das ein
könner machen dass mir
wieder lag sind mitten und also offen
kommunizierte aus tausend blumen
gewöhnlich sind unterschiedlich aber
einigkeit ist die körperlich mögliches
thema das ich das thema das mehr
wichtiger aus der frau aber sich fürs
gemeinsames thema ich wenig ist nur der
erste schritt zurück zeigen dabei mir
aber da war mir die sprache und das kann
ich gehe so der offenheit hört oder
zustrom aus man wird und nicht im foyer
schon rücksicht und einem eigentlich
standpunkt bremen als frau in einer
männerdomäne rats das herz ausschütten
und berichtet also bist du zu ihnen
markt würde dieser kurs und angst genau
und luxemburg
ich finde schon kaputt zu lösen wirklich
gut und ich finde ich gut
und natürlich gut dass der fci oder das
ist sind da findet heißt für sie ganz
massive definition von meiner gute maße
55 familie bezogen quartier ist vorbild
für mich sauber weil die gute zeichen
setzen
im beruf privat ehrenamtlich muttis
nachhaltigen versetzen heißem ihr
partner sie zumindest frau war
danke schon viele mal
im empfangsbereich der praxis sitzt
marco kniest frau daniela bürgen
die beiden kennen sich seit über 30
jahren und sind seit zehn jahren ein
paar
leben und arbeiten zusammen ja es klingt
sehr gut anfreunden konnte womit keiner
meine kinder christen wie das
funktioniere sind mir ein frühes
rometsch kussin apotheker sind zusammen
schaffe und die schrift ist sehr schön
und gut ja ja jeder die
kompetenzbereiche finanzchefin und
organisations chefin und macht die ganze
diagnostik und da war mir is muss also
blutentnahmen und ich bin nicht mit der
patientin im sprach sich nur und wenn
wenn das klare kompetenzverteilung
gesehen denn das kreisgebiet mit brühe
durch können wir jetzt so troge wurden
die was sie schon immer eine frau fragen
wollten und zu fragen trauten
doch welt vorstellen naja onkel zu den
männern im kloster engelberg gesellt
sich für einen kurzen auftritt maya
onken die ihrerseits seit jahren mit
frauen arbeitet ich weiß da war bewusst
ist dass eure frauen ständig obwohl ich
meine die säge mitte finanzen mit sobald
ein kontostand überführt und da ist
nicht fiktiv sondern alles was ihr tut
oder was eben nett sind wird kommentiert
also ein blumenstrauß plus 50 punkten
vergesse beträge - 20 ein nettes wort am
abend schaut sie wie hashes ko plus 100
m kraul es lothar bisky dsk - 200 und
frau sei geplant die säcke einfach nur
ihr hängt kranich dass er schon lange -
sie sind immer nett zu als sie hoffe ja
noch les das dauert bis rund um einen
bus der avd und dem präsentiert sie als
unterstand und b ist einfach absolut -
und das ist eigentlich der punkt wo noch
heute die griffe die demo mal eure
frauen vc marl unterstand so aktuell bei
dir
und da gibt eigentlich da wenn ich so
scharf und geld am ende vom monat
einbringen wie viele stirbt und dann
würdet ihr eure hunde weniger
unterschiedlich kommentiert meine
dreimal ehring oder seitdem europäisches
und das stadtspiel fahrer leute so
divers permanent diana rigg permanente
lehrte schon mit punktesystem eine
geniale funde und wird sicher eine
firmensprecherin grundzustand ist
seminarteilnehmer philipp ist marco
carini sohn und seine damalige freundin
wird im september seine frau
der dreh mit den beiden fällt in die
zeit des corona lockt 1 und findet per
skype statt
im letzten wurf freundin regelmäßig nach
ihrem gefühl dafür entwickelt zu merken
wie einst im grundzustand dienst oder
was geht denn am nächsten pluspunkt
die grossbank geht wenn die überrascht
hat anja befreit
und wenn ihr herum und immer alles parat
für natürliche reflex sie mit ganz
vielen anderen entschuldigung für
schwanz träumt und das ist dass ich für
mich ist das passt aber zum ganze marco
carini liebt die provokation sein
auftritt im club des schweizer
fernsehens sagte letztes jahr für
einiges aufsehen
es ist wie wenn man paul magnetische
pole einfach and magnetisiert und ihr
bevor also bekomme ich frage mich was
liegt manchmal schwierig mit ihm geprobt
um rede du kriegst gestorben das geht
nur versorgt konzern noch was ich immer
wurden die riesige man ruhig machen sich
immer mehr nicht
aber ich hatte das problem ich glaube
dass das das zuerst rhj merke dass david
redet dass die ideen ins offroad das
mikrofon abgestellt werden und so ein
zuschauer oder iphone bildschirm mit
bevor das mittel hat permanent trends
orientieren sich immer einig und waren
damit haben wir sozusagen zu meinem sehr
schwierige thema salz bestand probiert
so habe das verbrechen gigant mit
zugelost und
bis man muss klare rolle dass man muss
reden erwärme zwischendurch weil man das
tal hause skoda einfach die
professionalität und das verlange ich
den abläufen der andere sieht das mit
israel ist es ist für mich nicht und
nahm sehen dann sind und doch ein
komischer habe funde das sehen so viel
lüth und mir eine arztpraxis und ihre
eigentlich angst das ist
geschäftsschädigend ist wir sind den
haien und der heime heiko den tisch
geklopft werden im fernsehen und
wenigstens zweimal ch bin ja auch schon
beruhigt gesehen und habe von der doch
eigentlich nicht schlecht gelassen auf
diesen auftritt reagierte kommission
viele typisch gestört und daher auch
vehement zu arbeiten was sie niemals
gesagt und das ist sehr direkt sehr und
das könnte ich mir dann was gestörten
kann dass er direkt sich hat also etwas
kommunizieren
aber noch ist auch wieder gut verdient
das heißt ermittlungen auch adebar und
genauso kann ich genau ich bin wieder
alles in ordnung also meine seiten auf
das projekt uhr und das ist ein erledigt
noch daniela bürgin ist marco k s dritte
ehefrau
er ist ihr zweiter mann beide haben sie
je zwei erwachsene kinder
was typisch waren die promi vater habe
sich wie viel gespart für die fussball
was er hat auch noch etwas typisch
männlich ist oder wenn man sagt was
typisch männlichen statur alte villa hat
immer wieder alles probiert ist im leben
immer wieder ist endlich immer wieder
diese kenny garrett einmal pro monat an
alle zeit und dass das ist bliebe das
man nicht einfach so es funktioniert mit
den gern beruf sondern blieb da es kurz
machen ganz man ganz frau im hause ki
wie anderswo definitionssache richter
motto was immer mal zu heiß oder was mir
nehmen darunter versteht er macht alles
was ich auch mache daheim sich gar und
beinahe unterschiedlichkeit das ist für
mich ja auch schon mal vor der regie
nicht von der aura von charisma ist sie
ist spricht sich andere lieblichkeit wo
mehr pole tut sie müssen mich nicht
wegen der dauer weiblichkeit entdecken
sondern lust eigentlich sehr mit
produktionshalle bestimmt mit der
möglichkeit und ich finde wo mehr als
man gut tut eigentlich erfordert relativ
selten überfordert und das macht macht
ihm spaß
wir wollen punkten zwischen dem squad
umzudeuten und pause mit gewissen
nachdruck auf den punkt druck
und zum schluss noch ein ganz
eindeutiger zugang zum thema ganz man
sein zimmer jetzt schon erektion geräumt
verkaufe trinken müsste mit rené
regelung zum schluss dass die position
des löwen aus dem schlimm aus aber
[Applaus]
vorsicht auch dieser wirklich
[Musik]